- Thank you very much, Bobby.
I had a similar situation when I
was working at the British Library.
We'd just finished the
Centre for Conservation,
a $25 million project.
It was such a celebration.
The night before, the architects
of the British Library
died, but we decided
to go ahead with it, the celebration,
because in honor of him.
When Bobby told me the news just earlier,
we decided to go ahead with the talk
in Frank's honor.
I would have been
meeting with him tomorrow
as two newbies.
He was two months into being the
university librarian, and I'm six months
into being deputy director of
Harvard University Library.
We'll go ahead.
So, this is a talk that Bobby
invited me to give about a year ago.
It's an enormous privilege and honor
to be invited to give the talk.
Start off.
We'll turn the lights down in a second.
It's a privilege to be giving it
to this audience because
I was thinking about it.
There's only a couple of things to which
I think I can lay claim.
One of them is that I'm guessing that I'm
the only Brother Helen in the audience.
The reason that I'm Brother Helen is that
I'm an associate of the Artworkers Guild,
which was set up in the UK during
the Arts and Crafts movement.
We're all brethren,
hence the Brother Helen.
I was taken there and introduced to it
by Roger Powell, who
rebound the Book of Kells,
together with his partner,
Douglas Cockerell,
he rebound the Codex Sinaiticus,
and his son Sandy Cockerell.
They laid the foundation
of book and manuscript
conservation, I think, in the UK.
Their influence has traveled very widely.
For example, Peter Waters
at the Library of Congress.
Well, Bobby invited me to
give this talk last year.
I think I'm still slightly surprised
to have taken the train this morning
from Boston instead of having flown across
from Heathrow.
This time last year,
when Bobby invited me,
I was at the British
Library, where I was part
of the senior leadership team, and I
was head of collection care.
I was responsible for the care
of 115 million items and 300 terabytes
of electronic content.
Those collections and
that content, it ranged
from medieval manuscripts in papyri
and oracle bones, through
to literary authors' emails
and websites of the UK web domain.
In my time at the BL, we completed
the Centre for Conservation.
We'd recently finished the 135 miles
of storage, of a storage building
that built on the Yale-Harvard model.
High bay, high density,
robotic, low-oxygen storage.
1/2 a mile of stock a day was being moved
into that facility.
I was involved with a newspaper strategy,
which was dealing with 750 million pages
of physical newsprint.
The digital library system was underway.
I'd just helped establish
the digital preservation.
That went from seven years
ago, when there was not
a single digital preservation professional
in a UK library or archive,
and I had to poach from Australia,
to when I left, we'd
then just had a retreat.
Around the table, there
was now a hundred years
of experience in digital preservation.
I was also just finishing
the stewardship strategy
for the British Library's physical
and virtual collections
for the next 10 years.
That was a year ago when Bobby invited me
to give the talk.
Scroll forward a year, and I've now
been at Harvard six months.
I'm currently responsible for the programs
across the system of 73 libraries.
That's information systems, archives
and records management,
preservation, conservation,
high-density store and the
Office for Scholarly Communications,
which champions open access.
These provide the services
across the library system,
which you probably know is
a very decentralized system.
Plus, you may also know that at Harvard
last year, the president
and provost instigated
a task force to look at the future
of the entire 73-library system,
from a governance of funding
and a structural perspective.
On my second day, I joined
the task force's work.
It's looking at the strategic future
of the library system.
It's due to report in the near future,
and so it wouldn't be appropriate for me
to comment on that major
fundamental review now,
but there are already key directions
that came out clearly.
For example, working towards one
integrated collection
and being user-centric,
or putting the user as our primary focus.
Well, for this talk,
I'm going to pick out
five or six paradoxes
that I've been pondering
around preservation,
even though it's now not my primary focus.
As this is billed as a
personal and strategic
perspective, it's my take on things
through the lens of having just moved
3,276 miles and through the lens
of having journeyed from
an artisan conservation
to strategic management.
I'm going to use a couple of examples
from the British Library
because you probably
already know a lot about Harvard,
and may not be so acquainted with the BL.
A year ago, I was working
at the British Library,
one of the greatest research
libraries in the world,
and now I'm at Harvard,
one of the greatest
research libraries in the world.
The British Library now has a
well-integrated preservation
and conservation setup,
with which I'm extremely proud.
Harvard has an extremely
impressive preservation
and conservation setup.
On a personal note,
I'd like to pay tribute
to Jan Merrill-Oldham,
who retired last month.
Her forethought and very wise decisions
have created a very
professional department.
As an aside, if anyone wants to talk to me
at the reception, we'll be recruiting
to that post later in the year. (laughter)
The British Library has a stupendous
and slightly irrational
legacy from over 250 years.
Harvard has a phenomenal historical legacy
of over 350 years.
They both have magnificent pasts.
I'll start with a very
obvious, simple paradox.
Namely, that people
often think preservation
is all about the past, but to my mind,
it's all about the future.
It's about anticipating the future
rather than adhering to the past,
and being able to look
a user of the future
in the metaphorical eye and say,
"Well, we did our best
to meet present need
"and anticipate your needs."
That's also the user-centricity that
Harvard's task force is talking about.
From a simple one,
through the next paradox.
There's been lots of talk that the rise
in digital initiatives leads to the demise
of the book, and a lot of anxiety that
that leads to a demise in the need
for preservation.
Paradoxically, not
necessarily, and whatever,
it's not that simple.
Yes, last year, oh, excuse me, last week,
Amazon said it sold more
e-books on amazon.com
during the previous 30
days than print books,
that's both hardcover
and paperback combined,
of its best seller list.
Yes, we're seeing the complete
life cycle of the media.
Did you see that Sony
this week, last week,
actually, it stopped
making its Walkman tapes.
That's a 30-year full
life cycle come and gone.
Yes, Generation X, Generation
Y and Generation Zed,
all those digital natives, they have got
expectations of access to everything
at any time and any place, anywhere.
Brewster Kahle, the internet archiver,
he recently estimated that
a hundred million books
will be disposed of across the US
in the next 10 years.
These are not unique items, but if
they're disposed of,
ironically, they might
become more special.
So here's the paradox.
Brewster Kahle, one of the earliest people
to realize the fragility of websites
and do something about it by setting up
the Wayback Machine and
the Internet Archive
in order to preserve the web, so he,
quintessential internet archiver,
is setting up a physical repository.
He's welcoming and will
store discarded copies
as everyone digitizes and discards.
What the Brewster Kahle
example illustrates
is that the physical is taking on
greater significance when
its existence is threatened,
which is leading to a greater emphasis
on preservation, ironically, where there
has been concern that
preservation is threatened.
I'm going to read you a quote taken from
last month's launch of the
British Library's vision
for 2020.
To put this in context,
this strategic vision
was posted just ahead of the comprehensive
spending review, which
was a fundamental review
of all federal funding,
all federal spending
by the new coalition government.
It's looking at everything from defense
to education to health.
In the event, it made 19% cuts
in government spending
across the whole of the UK.
My colleague at the BL,
who'd been profiling
25% and 40% cuts, she
made the wry comment,
"I never thought I'd say, Helen,
"that 15% would be a good result."
Anyway, this is the BL's vision for 2020.
Could you turn the lights down, please?
"We estimate that by
2020, 75% of all titles
"worldwide will be published
in digital form only,
"or in both digital and print.
"Our ambition is to
preserve digital content
"for the long term, in order to safeguard
"our intellectual heritage
so that it can be used
"by future generations of researchers.
"As digital formats become the norm,
"our rich resource of physical content
"will become more precious.
"It is thus vital that
we continue to develop
"our world-class stewardship skills
"in conservation and preservation."
Paradoxically, more preservation
of more precious physical material
whilst also there's obviously the rise
in digital preservation.
This from an organization
that is absolutely
positioning itself in the forefront
of the digital world.
The prime minister
launched Digital Britain
from the British Library
when I was there last year.
Furthermore, (clears throat) digitization,
excuse me, (coughs) digitization can lead
to greater emphasis and importance
on the special physical, not less,
and virtualization is
leading to the creation
of new digital entities.
As the mass digitization initiatives,
such as Google, and the
boutique digitization
of small projects start to join up,
they make for a new critical mass,
a new massive digital entity that can
be linked and mined and studied and used
in ways that were
unimaginable, unimaginable,
until recently.
I'll illustrate this with the digitization
and virtual reunification
of the Codex Sinaiticus,
which is the earliest
existing text in the world
of the New Testament.
One of the only other claims I can make
is that until the 6th of July last year,
I was one of maybe three people alive
who had seen all the surviving manuscript
of the Codex Sinaiticus
in the four locations.
Namely, St. Catherine's
Monastery in Egypt,
from where the majority was taken
in the 19th century by Tischendorf,
to Leipzig in Germany, and then it went
to St. Petersburg and then to London.
On the 16th, excuse me, on the 6th of July
last year, the digitized manuscripts
were brought together virtually.
Instead of having been
seen by three people
in the world, on that day alone,
they were viewed by 20 million people.
The Codex Sinaiticus project digitized
all the leaves and fragments from
the four locations.
There are 347 leaves in the
British Library in London,
bought from the Russian government in 1933
for the equivalent of about $3 million.
They arrived, unbound, and were bound
into two volumes in 1935
by Douglas Cockerell.
When I worked for Roger Powell, he used
to tell us stories about
Cockerell's conservation
and binding of the Codex.
So from a personal point of view,
there was a lovely circularity in leading
the conservation of the
Codex Sinaiticus project
some 60 years later, and
finding in the archives
all the materials testing and all
the treatments and all the correspondence
between Powell and Cockerell.
Then, there were 43 leaves in
Leipzig University Library in Germany.
Those are currently unbound.
There were four portions of leaves
in the National Library of Russia
in St. Petersburg, and
those are currently framed.
Then there were some or all of 18 leaves
in St. Catherine's Monastery
in Mount Sinai in Egypt.
They were recovered by the monks
from the northern wall
of the monastery in 1975.
From a conservation point of view,
they're in the worst condition.
The project was essentially to digitize
the leaves and bring the
manuscript back together
on the web, to reunify it virtually,
but it was much more than that.
There was imaging under standard light
and raking light.
Then there's the content metadata.
There's a new transcription.
It's in Greek.
The text is in Greek, so there's a new
transcription into Greek.
There are translations into modern Greek,
Russian, German and English.
Then there's the physical description.
This physical description was part
of the conservation
element of the project,
with major collaboration with the
curatorial investigations,
with extensive examination
of the scribe link, the
codicological features,
the previous repairs,
the current condition,
the conservation undertaken and all
the surface characteristics
of the parchment.
For example, here you can see those curves
on the left-hand side.
Those striations made by the,
thought to be made by the
parchment makers' knives.
The same documentation
methodology was used
in each of the four location, and then
embedded in the website.
I'm not aware of this level of examination
being so systematically embedded
in any other such project.
It's great to hear, I've just learned
that it's been shortlisted for the
UK's Conservation Awards.
Then there's a whole series of essays
on the website, which are
being consistently added to.
Now, this was a seven-year,
$1 1/2 million project.
The next step was a much shorter,
less expensive project, to digitize
all the British Library's
Greek manuscripts,
building on what was learned from the
Codex Sinaiticus project
and using crowdsourcing.
What was being called, as
I left the British Library,
expertonomies, whereby scholars input
their research so that it wasn't just
BL experts writing the text.
Then there were folksonomies, whereby
non-scholars could input their,
so taking it from being a boutique
digitization project to a wider project
contributing to this
critical mass of content.
So here's the thing.
Here's the paradox.
Articulated on the day that
the world's earliest surviving text
of the New Testament
was virtually reunified,
on the day that 20 million people
saw it reunified, on the day that the term
Codex Sinaiticus was amongst the top 20
Google searches worldwide and on the day
that there were over 700 news articles
about the project, on that day,
on the 6th of July 2009, on The Guardian
newspaper's blog, Shirley Dent
of the Institute of Ideas, she said,
"We've long been aware that a plethora
"of literature can be made available
"through digitized open sources,
"such as Project Gutenberg.
"But, ironically, the
potential to make literature
"available online, in downloadable
"and now e-book reader format, has also
"been heralded as the
slow death of the book
"as we know it.
"What the Codex Sinaiticus
project illustrates
"is that the opposite could be true.
"Digital technology may not only preserve
"hard codices that, even with the best
"conservation intentions,
will always be vulnerable
"to the ravages of time.
"We may in fact be on the brink
"of digitally resurrecting, reinterpreting
"and reinvigorating that past."
My third paradox is around the inevitable
classic tension between preservation
and access, which has been debated
since the beginning of preservation
as a profession.
Personally, I've pretty
much changed my view
since starting as a naive and idealistic
conservator at the
Victoria and Albert Museum,
when I first thought
the best way to preserve
fragile materials was to prevent damage
by keeping people away from
fragile special collections.
Now my starting point is how
to make things accessible,
and then work backwards.
There's an inherent paradox
in making material available.
Nicely summarized, I think, in a recent UK
research project entitled Catch 22.
The Catch 22 was that
"access to heritage objects
"brings social benefit.
"Greater access brings
greater social benefit.
"Greater access brings greater damage.
"Greater damage brings
reduced social benefit."
Access brings social benefit.
Greater access, greater social benefit.
Greater access, greater damage.
Greater damage, reduced social benefit.
One approach to squaring
this particular circle
is to take a strategic
management approach.
Whenever we make material available,
we're putting it at risk.
I was very much involved
in collection security
in my last role.
Think Forbes Smiley III, Farhad Hakimzade.
There was a case reported only last week
of the ex-department head of
the National Archives here arrested
in his house by FBI agents.
But the risk to collections is far wider
than from theft.
There's a whole risk
and compliance industry
that analyzes probability
and severity of risks.
In the world of conservation
and preservation,
there are various methods for assessing
risk of collections.
For example, that developed at the
Canadian Museum of Nature.
Most of you all know this method,
but it defined agents of deterioration
and risk factors.
For example, earthquakes, pests,
environmental facts, dissociation,
which is a renaming of that previously
somewhat pejorative custodial neglect,
and security and so on.
Ironically, I think an integrated
risk management approach
encourages innovation
and entrepreneurship, which
we hear so much about,
and it encourages risk taking because
it encourages an organization
to identify risks,
identify mitigation of risks and actually
to be explicit about what
its risk appetite is.
It compels an organization to acknowledge
what's risky, identify the unknown,
give a name to fear and fear of failure.
Then that can help inform your strategy.
Risk assessments were carried out on all
the collections of the British Library.
Here's the British Library.
There was a risk assessment of all
the digital collections,
which helped determine
the digital preservation strategy.
For example, we discovered
there was already
a 3% loss of legal deposit CDs.
Then we did a risk assessment of the
physical collections, using the
Canadian Museum of Nature's methodology.
The two highest risks.
I was gonna ask what
people thought they were,
but I can't see anyone,
actually. (laughter)
Would you shout out
(laughs) what do you think
were the two highest risks of the
150 million physical items
at the British Library?
- [Audience Member] Being lost.
- [Helen] Being lost.
Any others?
- [Audience Member] Water damage.
- [Helen] Water damage.
Any others?
- [Audience Member] Terrorism.
- [Helen] Interesting.
Actually, if you can see,
there's the British Library.
Can you see behind is St. Pancras Station,
which is the new Eurostar station,
which is actually an
issue for the security
of the British Library.
The two highest priority, excuse me,
the two highest risks were, actually,
wear and tear, given that 3 million items
are issued every year
in the reading rooms,
and security, which is the price
of giving access to 400,000 visits
to the reading rooms, but they can
obviously be mitigated.
I'd be very interested, actually,
either in the debates or, excuse me,
any questions afterwards
or at the reception
if anyone else has done
these risk assessments
because I think there's a huge value
in comparing results.
I do know of another organization
which have had a very unexpected result,
which found that one of its major sources
of risk was from actually having boxed
so much of its material.
It was a very high use collection.
As the material was being transported
to the reading rooms,
it was getting a lot of,
it was very fragile material in boxes
that were too big for it and was actually
causing a lot of damage.
If we'd done this risk
assessment 10 years ago
at the British Library, I'm pretty sure
that the results would
have been different.
I think one of the
highest risks would have
been from environmental factors,
but since there's been massive improvement
and improved buildings over 15 years
that will take the BL from before 1998,
when it moved into that building,
you could say none of its collections,
0% of its collections were in satisfactory
environmental conditions.
As it moved in there, which was where 1/2
the collections went, that went to 42%.
Then with the completion
of the massive new
storage building, when that's full,
the new density store is full is 2011,
it'll go to 66%.
Over 15 years, 2/3 of the collections
will have gone into satisfactory
environmental conditions.
That minimizes that risk.
I know the Canadian Museum of Nature,
their risk profile changed over time.
They had identified
storage as a major issue.
Then they made improvements
and mitigated it.
As to Harvard, well, watch this space.
I think I'll finish, actually,
with a couple of paradoxes
and contradictions
around funding.
We'll illustrate it with the
British Library's Centre for Conservation,
which some of you may
already have visited.
Preservation is the custodian and champion
of long termism, and yet, ironically,
it's often trapped in
short-term decision making
and funding.
A nice paradox that I've observed in my
first few months here
in an endowment culture
is that a lot of preservation is supported
by non-core funding and soft endowment
or fundraised money.
The good side of this paradox is that
it does generally seem attractive
to donors and endowments, but I would
be very, very interested in your thoughts
and experience on this.
Well, at the BL, I encountered
an infuriating paradox.
When we were fundraising
for the $25 million
Centre for Conservation, which I
was very heavily involved
with over nine years,
from its conception
through to its completion.
This is the back of the British Library
and is the Centre for Conservation,
which is the first new build since
that St. Pancras building
was completed in 1998.
There's the Eurostar station at the back.
This was a major project.
It included state-of-the-art studios
for audio and book conservation.
Fundamental, absolutely fundamental
to the whole concept was public access.
These studios were designed to have
weekly behind-the-scenes
tours for the public
and lectures and seminars.
The entrance is a permanent exhibition
about what is inside the building.
For example, on the right there,
there's an interactive where you,
as a visitor, can make decisions about
how to conserve, I think it was a
19th-century printed book.
Or you can preserve a sound recording,
such as, I think this was
Nelson Mandela's trial tapes.
You can compare your restored version
with that of an audio archivist's.
There was a huge emphasis
on training and development
of both staff and also of the profession.
We set up a degree, a foundation degree,
in conjunction with the
University of the Arts.
It was sponsored
internships in book, paper
and audio conservation and preservation.
This was a high-risk project.
It was the first capital
fundraising project
for the British Library.
The irony was that we could get funding
for the training, for the internships,
and we could get funding
for the public programs.
This exhibition area, we could have sold
the naming rights five times over.
But for the conservation,
we couldn't get funding, as that was seen
as a core mandate of the British Library.
Ironically, fundraising for the building
was challenging, as well, even though
usually people will support buildings
and equipment, and not
what goes on in them.
Yet, the irony was if we
didn't get the funding
for the building, we
couldn't do the activities.
We couldn't do the
conservation, the training,
the public programs that
went on inside them.
Lots of paradoxes, lots of ironies,
lots of contradictions.
What are some of the lessons from my
professional journey from
artisan conservation?
When Roger Powell, he used to introduce
all his assistants as fourth generation
Arts and Crafts.
I've gone from artisan conservation
to strategic management in
large-scale research libraries
in a climate of cloud
computing and crowdsourcing.
Well, the spectrum of preservation
has got bigger, broader, wider
and more complicated.
From artisan conservation at one end
of the spectrum, there are
many, many more shades.
Through a whole rethinking
of environmental parameters
of storage and energy efficiency,
through to collections-wide
risk assessment,
through to bitstream preservation,
emulation and virtual universal computing.
The spectrum of preservations got bigger,
broader and wider.
All this chopping of preservation
and conservation into little chunks
of book and paper and photographs
and audiovisual and digital,
I don't think it makes sense anymore.
They're all part of that
continuum of information,
of information mediums, and
they're all interconnected.
For those working in the field,
no job is unchanged.
Mine has changed exponentially,
almost beyond recognition.
No job should be unchanged, and no job
will be unchanged.
For those involved with
any aspect of preservation,
everyone's been touched by these issues
and should be actively engaged with them
in order to remain relevant.
Are the next generation being trained
with that full spectrum?
There's usually a time lag.
Where's my successor?
Are there enough people in the system
who already are spanning this spectrum?
Preservation has changed
and then the nature
of what's being preserved has changed.
We still have the legacy
of physical collections
and digitization has become
a lot more sophisticated.
As the critical mass grows and projects
join up, and digital
scholarship mines data
and text in new ways, that's challenging
some of the assumptions that underpinned
preservation as it was practiced
even a generation ago.
Now we can use advanced technology to make
rare objects more accessible, not less.
Artificially reconstructed objects
can be more authoritative
than the authentic fragments.
Coming full circle to my first paradox
about preservation being about the future
more than the past, with
these futuristic ventures,
we can be more true to the past.
Thank you once again,
Bobby, for inviting me.
I was very honored to be
asked to give this talk.
Thank you all for coming.
I'm extremely honored you all came.
Thank you for your patience.